so I'm okay
I'm honored to be here at Stanford yet
again this their this title is is way
too cute I couldn't resist it given my
history here of speaking at this forum
about the nature of time in physics and
what we're really going to talk about
here is going to be a time timeout
less data center and we'll we'll have
some fun here talking about computer
science more than the physics as I have
done in previous lectures so we're
really talking about here is Alan Karp
we also have some team members here
which are here to help us with the
demonstration that we're going to do so
fingers crossed and way to the demo gods
that that this actually works and we'll
and we'll see what we do when we when we
try to get that going
so what is what is this talk about it's
about cloud computing and about this
paradigm shift that's going on in our
industry in our society right now big
movements to public clouds even the
private clouds are starting to shrink
and everyone is talking about
outsourcing their IT to the public cloud
because it's just too difficult to
manage it's just too awkward it's just
too failure failure prone and it's just
too complex to manage on your own
so we see that this massive movement
which is now projected to be in the
trillions of dollars over the next few
years is is going to be an opportunity
it's an opportunity for everyone in
computer science and a opportunity for
everyone in business to be able to use
this you new utility in some interesting
ways but there are some taxes and we've
identified three taxes the first one is
the tax of complexity which is things
just get more difficult to manage as
they get larger the second one is the
tax of fragility which is they become
more brittle as they get larger and some
would say that that's because of the
first tax and that the third one is the
vulnerabilities we all know that the
entire all the systems that were working
on both in the back end as well as in
our private machines are hopelessly
insecure security is an unsolved problem
it's a massive opportunity for someone
who can solve it or at least address it
in some ways that provides significant
mitigation of the the break-ins that are
happening on a daily basis now but
security is last in our list of things
because what we realize is the kind of
things that you need to do when you are
recovering from a perturbation and I'll
call a perturbation you know a disaster
a failure a physical attack or or a
cyber attack the thing you want to do
the most is you want to recover as fast
as possible because the time to recover
set your availability equation and makes
your systems much more available for
everyone so we'll talk about these three
taxes today and we believe that we have
some simple ways of addressing them with
some very minor protocol features that
could lie you know in between the
communications of computers inside
large-scale data centers so I noticed
that on Twitter today this morning in
fact this afternoon in fact there was
this quote it was we are very good at
building complex software systems that
work ninety-five percent of the time of
course it doesn't matter how small our
fraction is if it's not zero it becomes
very large as we scale our systems and
that's the whole point as systems get
larger they fail more often and they get
the run and those failures run into
failures of failures which run into
cascades of failures and one of the ways
of looking at this is the the kind of
things we're going to talk about today
which is the the usual errors of human
failure and complexity but also this is
from the the Langley a formal methods
program which basically says that the
design errors are increasingly becoming
the most serious culprit now we think we
can design something that will eliminate
many of those taxes that we're described
on the previous slide so we'll see if
our reasoning is reason is reasonable
here and I'm sure there's lots of smart
people in the audience here will have
some excellent questions
so the keikain computer science problems
let me remind you I'm going to put these
all up at once the the reliable
consensus problem is basically based on
the generals paradox the fact that there
is no fixed number of messages which can
complete the protocol and guarantee a
reliable solution in an environment
where messages can get lost okay we all
know this this is the the conventional
view of the generals paradox very
closely related to that is this
indistinguishability of a failed process
and a slow process and a failed link and
the fact that you can't distinguish them
means that we have to take our beloved
ideas of asynchronous systems and we
have to reintroduce synchrony of some
kind and we normally do that by adding
in a timeout a duration and the problem
is no matter what we set that duration
to were always creating a race condition
between marking the process at the other
end of that wire as being suspects or
you know the the acknowledgment coming
back at the same time and that is at the
heart of most distributed systems
problems and of course that also ties
into the Fisher lines and and policy
result the impossibility result that
says that you you you can't have a
system
succeed even with one failure this isn't
even a consensus problem yet in an
asynchronous system if you have one
failure the system will stop so this is
why we have consensus protocols and why
people like Leslie Lamport of develops
or founded an entire literature and and
discipline around how to do consensus so
what we're going to describe to you
today is a key idea the key idea is
think about liveness differently I did
promise I would talk a little bit about
time and I and I will but but the whole
idea is can we use the link instead to
give us a new notion of liveness
instead of using the processes inside
each of the nodes to be clicking away on
the time stamp counter and when it
overflows a certain number we say okay
timeout let's go and see if that thing
that I set off some time
as complete now this is a core issue in
in computer science and let's say let's
describe the problems the problems are
the rent ordering is hard this generals
problem means that if you've got three
things going on here P Q and R then you
can't tell an event a process R has
happened before an event a process Q
unless P caused R in some way and so
this word caused and causal comes up
quite a lot in computer science it also
has a a checkered history in physics too
but that's not something we're going to
be discussing today what we've got what
we claim is that we can provide
on-demand causal trees and that when you
when you use them in the right kind of
way you can guarantee when they are
stable the kind of properties that you
need to provide much stronger guarantees
in the liveness properties of
distributed algorithms but that's not
enough if they when they're stable is
all file and good but can you provide
those same guarantees through failure
and recovery that's actually a much
harder problem and what we'd like to
show you today in which we hope to
demonstrate is a fundamental primitive
which is a new way of looking at solving
this problem so we're going to introduce
you today to something called atomic
information transfer and this is if you
like the moral equivalent of the copper
and swap instruction inside the
processes in the shared memory systems
but on the message between machines and
it will give is a property which is
extremely hard to get any other way
which is exactly once semantics so keep
that in mind the second problem is
consensus is hard failure detectors the
way the modern way to do failure
detectors is statistical it's called an
unreliable failure detector you're
assuming that the pass you're trying to
use to get access or reach the thing
you're talking to as likely to fail so
you use a statistical approach to
basically try multiple pass and and that
unreliable failure detector is got an
entire body of literature that you can
go and look at what we think we can do
is much better than that we can go to
algorithms like two-phase commit which
is a fail stop algorithm
but it's vulnerable to coordinator
failure if you have a coordinator fairly
just at the wrong time you really there
is no safety proof and so that was this
is well known 25 years ago this was
discovered and and then there was this
notion of well let's solve that problem
that walking problem in two-phase commit
with three phase commit and three phase
commit is considerably more complex but
at the same time we didn't discover that
the three phase commit doesn't have a
liveness proof and so we'll return here
between these safety and lively prop
leibniz properties in distributed
systems are we beginning to realize now
as as computer scientist that you have
to have both to have a system that works
you have to have a combination of
aliveness and safety you can't have one
without the other it's meaningless
so Paxos another very famous example of
a fairly clever algorithm where we you
can create a robust algorithm but it's
hard to understand and get right Paxos
is very famous for its many different
variants and it's also very famous for
people not being able to understand the
Leslie Lamport some description obvious
and you find I find the population of
people fairly evenly distributed between
those who like his first paper and those
who like the taxes made simple paper and
I'm and as we hope on the audience here
both of them may be wrong this is a it's
an interesting problem bill because what
Leslie Lamport did is he led us right to
the edge of a really difficult problem
to reason about and one of the questions
we've been saying in previous poram
'he's about the notion of time in
computer science is that the reason why
we can't reason about them properly is
because we don't we don't actually
understand what time is and the
physicists of course already know this
but we're struggling with it right now
and I'm hoping that we're going to make
some progress so we're going to say that
causal trees make the rules in impact
sauce robust and it makes them easier to
understand and especially easier to
verify so why is there all this problem
well the networks are flaking this is a
very this picture comes from Cal
Kingsbury is there a fir blog about how
to how to torture this databases and he
does a very good job of putting up
very simple assistant together and
putting arbitrary network partitions
between multiple processes ensuring
where the algorithms fail without even
any misunderstanding about what time is
they're all running on the same machine
and they still have pata you can have
partitions which create misbehavior and
these distributed algorithms so what we
find though is that is the app
developers really blame the network they
say the network can't communicate
something wrong with a network a bit and
their argument is that the networks drop
delay duplicate and reorder packets and
on the other hand a the network folks
will say that the app started blame and
they will say you know it's because of
the end-to-end principle which we agreed
on you know decades ago is the right way
to do things and the reasoning behind
this is that you have to have the
failure recovery in the endpoints the
argument is there are some things that
you just can't recover from unless the
endpoint has all the information it
needs therefore there's no point in
keeping any stay in the intermediate
switched nodes now it is one or the
other correct our view is this our view
is that both of them are incorrect and
it's going to take a fresh refreshed
view of things to provide provide a good
solution so what does how what happens
when you get to a point where these
things are failing you can see where I'm
going with this right so we have these
switches in between our computers and
I'm going to describe them as dreadful
and this is a wonderful acronym that
Alan came up with he's very good at
these things
dreadful means that they drop reorder
delay and duplicate packets and so one
of the things you could do is you could
say okay well there's four failure modes
in our hazard list and we can try and
figure out how to solve them each by one
by one but the network people don't do
that the network people say no I was our
solution to everything you drop the
packet you know TCP will get the hint
that we were you're not passing things
through all the way to the end if it
finds it doesn't get the acknowledges
and it will back off that's what it's
all about but even though TCP was
designed to give you in order delivery
guarantees you don't get that when you
do an application retry all in order
guarantees are out the window
if you have to do an application retry
so this causes a whole bunch of
interdependent failures things that you
didn't think should be related but they
end up being directly related and so
this causes you know with either Asia
coded systems it causes reconstruction
storms you know and with with
distributed systems in general on your
failure detectors it causes timeout
storms and with other big failures that
happen at Amazon you've heard probably
several times now they have these things
called gossip storms where these
statistical behavior of these of these
mechanisms we're talking about earlier
the gossip protocols they all suddenly
start to sing at the same time and these
cause cascade failures which basically
means that you've got a switch that will
misbehave for a few seconds which causes
the application to misbehave for a few
minutes which causes the database to be
out for two hours now you would say well
okay that can't happen very often well
it it didn't used to happen very often
at least not more than like once a week
you know maybe 10 years ago but in large
data centers these things can happen
multiple times a day and you will see
them from there all the different cloud
vendors will will have reports if you
read the the root cause analysis of
things that generally end up being
cascade failures and and often it's
because there are two failure modes
there in the system that are only
exposed under certain conditions but in
a large enough system anything that can
go wrong will and so we have two billion
tweet the solution that we think we have
to come up with to be able to address
this problem is to simplify so all of
these all of these companies have had
reports in the last few months in lushy
or so where they've had major failures
major catastrophes that put their
systems out for multiple hours the
simmer there there are outages have cost
hundreds of millions of dollars the
Delta one in particular was 150 million
dollars for example and all of these
vendors are constantly faced with the
problem that these cascade failures will
lead to this large-scale misbehavior or
instability of their systems we're no
longer dealing with something that any
single human mind can
stand anymore so therefore we have to go
to a higher level of technical
understanding or science to be able to
say how do we understand and deal with
these things at large scale it takes a
different way of thinking about things
so let me take you out of the the kind
of technical mode here a moment and do
some some historical context and
describe a big idea that was the world
wide web the world wide web is a is a
very large was originally you know the
the ARPANET and what happened was we
found that Tim berners-lee came along
and he had some nice ideas in fact he
had a great idea which was just two
simple sets of rules and the simple sets
of rules were a document language which
was HTML and a connection protocol which
is HTTP simple rules neighbors talking
to each others at least within this IP
space and what that did is it created
these one-way links on this revolution
that happened with these one where links
was we could navigate from link to link
to link to link and we could go
wandering around the internet on this
World Wide Web which is where we are
today
wonderful thinking of things from first
principles about how we can can can
basically manage things these one-way
links I want you to keep in mind because
they're asymmetric there's a tail on the
arrow and there's a head on the arrow so
what this allowed us to do is it allowed
mere mortals to be able to get their
computers to talk to each other and that
was really quite amazing ordinary human
beings your sister your mother your your
children you know everyone could use a
computer now to be able to find things
out then there was a second harvest and
we're living this right now and the
second harvest we call cloud computing
cloud computing is outsourcing your IT
and it's so successful that the entire
industry is moving that in that
direction as like an um almost
unstoppable juggernaut and it's a good
thing because the economies of scale
that you can get in large mega data
centers is really quite excellent and
you also
because there's a shortage of human
expertise to be able to run these
systems especially security experts we
Gartner has predicted that by 2019
there will be one to two million
unfilled security engineer positions for
data centers because it is such an
administrative ly intensive operation
big opportunity here if we can address
that so that's what cloud computing is
we decided to shamelessly steal before
process that Tim berners-lee had for
thinking about how to deal with this and
we call our company earth computing the
the tagline here is the the solid ground
beneath the clouds and that's probably
about as much marketing as you get out
of the media
but but what we're trying to say here is
that well what if you had you know two
simple sets of rules and those two
simple sets of rules were a graph
language we call it the graphical
machine language which describes how
things are relate to each other and a
connection protocol and the connection
protocol we're going to describe to you
is called the earth computing link
protocol now there's something very
interesting special what we think about
links which is what we're going to talk
to you about right now so there you go
earth computing is the is a solid ground
beneath the clouds so well what we mean
by sod we mean that it's more resilient
furthermore first of all we mean it's
simpler number one it's simpler number
two it's more resilient and number three
it's more secure that's what we think we
can create by taking a fresh look at how
we relate these machines together and
how they talk to each other inside data
centers this is only a data center
solution it doesn't work across the one
we have some ideas on how it might do
but it's a much more difficult problem
trying working get it to work over
legacy protocols but it's added a data
center we can do something that you
can't do anywhere else so these
distributed systems primitives I
compared at the beginning of this talk
that this comparin swap instruction
which is an atomic instruction that we
all use inside our shared memory systems
all in processes all cores can talk down
to the same shared memory system and the
atomic primitive there is called compare
and swap and it's it's led to a
a lot of the latest way of doing things
now is called a lock free data
structures which is extensively used in
all of our operating systems and all of
the new work that's been done on
distributed systems but it gives us all
these concurrency libraries are now
being transformed over to using these
lock free data structures but they're
all leveraging this thing called compare
and swap it's made from an atomic
read-modify-write instruction so you're
reading something from memory you're
modifying it inside your processor and
you're writing it back or you're
instructing some other machine to do
that for you or like remote DMA for
example is a an approach sister on some
networks so this gives us that
concurrent safety it gives us the non
blocking it turns out and finally after
15 or 20 years of work on this by the
academic community we're starting to be
able to make them perform as well as the
the previous locking based systems but
much more safely we would like to
introduce the idea that what's missing
is the communication messages between
computers
neither similar otama sati principle
right now we we have a process that
Peter Alvaro
tells me is called a bang bang bang
theory of networking which is basically
bang I want something I need wait for
the acknowledging when it doesn't come
back you go bang again and say hey I
need it now and you still have it and
then you go bang bang and what happens
is everyone in the data center all goes
bang bang bang bang bang at the same
time when the network gets congested so
now he's starting to see why this
cascade failure start to happen and what
we're trying to do about it so we
believe that these atomic information
transfer the key idea essentially is
let's create a recoverable token that
can be sent and if it if if the
operation that we want the process and
the other side to do doesn't succeed it
sends as the token back it's a it's a
mechanism for doing this atomicity in
messages which allows us an opportunity
for doing recovery in a much better way
so there you go deterministic in order
delivery when you ask for it it's a
reversible token which says I can send
it and sometimes I can send more than
one but there's a small number very
small number it's only yeah it's only a
small amount
roll back that you can do with these
things and it creates this process of an
aversive atomic mechanism so
deterministic recoverability
and it's durable if a failed system
fails if a link fails we can still
recover those tokens that's the way it's
designed now it is one of the things
that we have thought about in the way
that we're going to show you the
networks here that is that typically
computers are much less reliable than
switches and routers and the reason for
that is because the software crashes
switches you know we've got some pretty
hard quorum firmware in them that and
mostly hardware so when they're doing
things at very high speed you know you
can push them to the limits and they
don't fall over whereas that's not quite
so true of our operating systems today
most of the time so the while operation
is the normal way you do this with a
shared memory system the the equivalent
would be for AIT would be a similar kind
of line that you would have in your code
in other words we're saying that you
can't build robust systems without both
of these primitives and once you realize
that you need both then you start to
realize that you can do cover ability in
ways that wasn't possible for and this
is necessary as we're building systems
very large so I we've time this present
this this presentation to be about 45
minutes and we that's including the demo
we have plenty of time at the end for
questions on camera and there are
certain questions that I would reserve
the right to not answer on camera
because there's a there's a proprietary
nature to some of the things that we're
doing although we don't mind sharing it
to people who are academically
interested in what we're doing so
typically the way a data center is
constructed is you have a whole bunch of
servers and then above the servers you
have this multi-level closed network
which is used for the shared
interconnections between these machines
and this was all well and good when most
of our traffic was going north to south
they know up to the internet and down to
the servers but these days in most
modern data centers most of the traffic
is actually east-west so this computers
at the bottom those servers I actually
want to talk laterally with each other a
lot more than they want to talk up but
they're forced to go up you know
sometimes you know it's
hops herp and then three hops down in
order to be able to talk to a server the
right might be in the adjacent rat to
them for example what we've done is said
well what if we had a system that didn't
have any switches what if we did our own
routing people have tried this many many
times before and we think we understand
why they haven't succeeded we think that
we can build a system that will be more
successful in in building distributed
algorithms on top of than the current
system with shared network switches
which will drop delayed duplicate and
reorder packets so that's the basically
the claim so what we have on the on the
right hand side here is just rows of
servers you know racks in a in a data
center and notice that there's some some
some links missing here and there's some
noes missing that's because that's how
it is in a real data center real data
centers are never a perfect you know
mesh of anything you can't you know
build a a code a Cartesian coordinate
addressing system on this and expect it
to work because these things fail in the
middle so what we do instead is we build
spanning trees on every single node we
discover what wiring is already in there
and Alton will show you how that works
in a moment which matters which means
that not only it when you first bring
these systems up okay you discover
what's actually there you can also adapt
as you go along as things are failing
and unadjusted and growing as the data
center grows how does it compare to a
way that people do things today today
people have a firewall at the edge of
the the data center we all know that
that doesn't work because all the
attacks come from inside the data center
today typically applications escalating
to the operating system you know they
will turn on the neck into promiscuous
mode and they'll send a a few
well-placed dart poison packets out to
the switch and the switch will then
start to sing and then you get to be
able to like see who's talking to who
and then in a hop over to another system
and and basically entry intrusion these
days is basically a graph problem and
and all the attackers thinking graphs is
a well-known Twitter statement all
attackers thinking graphs the defenders
thinking lists as long as the attackers
thinking graphs they will win so what
we're doing is saying that's just
something different here let's have
these nodes and links that connect to
each other which is the picture on the
right hand side but we're able to use
algorithms that divide up these systems
instead of having human hands on
keyboards editing ackles and if you can
have an algorithm that can move these
boundaries between the orange and the
blue and the and the yellow tenants then
what happens you can make them dynamic
you can make them you know grown shrink
over the day as you want to use things
for different purposes you can make them
adapt when you have a DDoS attack for
example but the thing to remember here
is that we can build into this system as
a thing that would if he said sitting
here a few months ago he said the
problem of security is confinement it
was solved in the 1970s and the
difficulty is that we've tried to
leverage cryptography ever since to try
and assume that we can get confinement
from that and all we done is we've
created this explosion of complexity in
key management so what if we could
actually get confinement in other words
Hardware in forced confinement of
packets to the areas that we want here
and what we're describing here today is
just the basic protocol primitive that
allows us to to manage a single link in
a much more intelligent way than we've
done before so let's let's pick draw a
bigger picture here what we're doing is
taking the whole data set so the big
blue thing that you can see and we're
fitting the smaller number of computers
inside of that which are directly
connected to each other in other words
these machines are connected one up one
down one left one right and across the
corners if you want in the words though
they're talking to their neighbors with
short cables and we can start small we
can start just in half a rack inside a
customer's environment that wants to say
I want to run some access systems inside
here that are really super reliable can
I do that and then they realized that
that works really well and they give us
a cup of racks and then they give us
half a dozen tries and then a year later
they give us half a row and then three
years later we've got we're taking up
the entire row in the data center in
other words you can try this out in the
small
if it works you can start to expand it
into the production environments as
you're finding it useful and we think
that that's going to be a valuable thing
to do so keep in mind that the earth
core here is made up of two kinds of
cells we call themselves these are just
compute storage networking packet
handling the red ones connected the
outside world so obviously they have to
be bridges of some kind or membranes to
keep out the bad stir from the outside
and the dark red stuff is is not
connected to the outside at all it's uh
next you cannot express their endpoint
you can't express an address they can
talk to them from outside and this is
true both on the outside of the inside
as well as from one cluster of tenants
to another cluster of tenants they
literally are as if that there
they've been physically severed from
their wire from their cables let's take
away all the complexity here and just
simplify this right down to what are we
talking about here these individual
nodes which we're making this hexagon
shape here to imply only one thing and
that there is that is that there is ice
is a finite number of ports on these
things it's more than you normally have
on a server in which is like three or
four but it's a lot less than you would
have on a switch it turns out and what
the magic is that we've discovered this
Goldilocks zone of how many ports that
you need is in the range of guess it
seven plus or minus two a very famous
number but it turns out that some very
interesting things happen when you have
that number of ports they forces you to
use multi-hop behavior which in general
in networking you think is a bad idea
but it turns out to be a really good
idea when you're trying to build
self-organizing systems now those are
the cells there's a cell agent in the
middle it might be it might be an actor
system for example but the next and the
network interface controllers you know
the fan-out from those and have
connectors on them but a really
interesting access aspect of this is
there's blue things we have taken the
Knicks and the cable between them when
we plug them together and we've made
that link a first-class object
and that means that we can put things on
them that will be remembered when the
link breaks in fact the the protocols
that we use keep complementary
information on both ends and we'll give
you some use cases after we've shown you
how where we're working with this now
what we're leading to with this so
between any two cells I can have this
private bipartite relationship and that
bipartite relationship is extremely
important to the theory behind how these
protocols work you have to be able to
exchange conserved quantities between
these two lengths but you could because
you can do that in a link by link basis
you can compose these over multiple
links now I'll give you a heads up as to
how that might look at look now let me
go back here one second here why would
you want to do this you would want to do
this because you could basically replace
timeouts
you can replace heartbeats you can
create I'm gonna call it a temporal
intimacy or a presence management
between each of these nodes or between a
set of nodes in a something like a tree
in a way that you can't do any other way
allowing you to eliminate heartbeats and
timeouts so whether is this going there
is a very fundamental problem Moses in
Halpern when the SEM price for something
called common knowledge and many of you
are probably very familiar with that
paper and so what we've done is we've
kind of figured out how to circumvent
the common knowledge problem so keep
that in mind as we go through this and
we're totally open to questions and
answers afterwards but let me just put
something in your mind here if we're if
I'm going to compose this presence
management across multiple of these of
these nodes then this is the picture
that I find most people kind of get it
they understand it when I show them this
and and it say okay well that's a nice
toy boat but you know what happens you
know with the we know with a real system
whoops sorry
that's not working I did went on all
right so it's uh that's very interesting
no that should go too I'm gonna show you
this later after Alan's done the
presentation all right so it's working
all right good
finally oh I see what's going on I can't
see it here hmm my local displays are
showing so give you a kind of a feel for
what's going on here we are ignoring
time in fact we're really thinking about
time in a totally different way than
most people do but you can see here that
if I start with an application over here
that talks Witten there it's network
asset layer down here and says please
guarantee that this thing gets over to
this thing over here and then it gets
taken off that the thing that's going on
in the middle is a is a kind of temporal
intimacy which is much much stronger
than we're normally used to having in a
net in a bang-bang-bang networking
environment where we have to use
timeouts so it's a one way of thinking
about it so I'd like to move on to the
demo and it introduced at sushi who is
going to be on the keyboard here and
then hand over to Ellen that's who to
describe what we're doing so I don't
know if you guys know this but Paul is
the bravest computer scientist in the
world he once gave a talk on a paper by
Leslie Lamport with Leslie Lamport in
the audience that's a very brave
computer scientist I am NOT brave but I
am foolhardy and I am going to attempt
to give you a live demo while being
taped for the internet so so what we
have here they don't let me touch
equipment so it's ooh she's going to do
all the what we have here is Marge and
Homer and they're connected through a
switch and they're happily pinging each
other all right now what I'm going to do
is I am going to disconnect Marge and
after a few seconds she's going to
realize that some
he's gone wrong you can see up there
that something you can see something's
gone wrong
Homer on the other side on the other
hand doesn't know about it he's talking
to the switch he's still connected to
the switch and thus he's sending his
packets to the switch now the switch is
desperately trying to find a route to
Marge which means in a real Network it's
spewing out packets all over the place
taking up the and with that could be
used for useful work
and finally Homer this is actually about
45 seconds figured out that something's
gone wrong we can plug them back in we
can plug them back in and then they will
start pinging each other again quite
happily this is the problem in in big
networks as we have timeouts that we
have to deal with so if the switch is
the problem what if I connected them
directly okay so I connect them directly
and now you can see that they are
happily pinging each other and when I
disconnect the link it takes a few
seconds it's still a timeout of course
the network protocol doesn't know that
there's no switch there might be a
switch but also the recovery process is
so onerous that it's worth waiting a few
seconds just to see if maybe it gets
fixed so that's the way things work in a
conventional Network how do things work
in ours so we're going to bring up a
display we've got four ports on each
machine that are running our protocol
and we're going to have a display that's
going to show the activity on those
ports and of course we got an error
dialog it's not just Windows that does
that
there's Marge and there's Herbie display
see I'm in shock cause trouble even when
I stand close to equipment I don't even
have to touch it to cause trouble
all right so with each of the four port
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
plug this orange cable into some port
now
with TCP you have to be careful which
port because of course the address
depends on the port but with our
protocol it doesn't matter which is a
good thing cuz I'm kind of careless and
once I plug it in what you're gonna see
is as soon as the lights come on on the
NEX these things become alive and you
can see now because this is a private
link I'm not wasting any bandwidth by
using it so rather than use timeouts
what we're doing is we're pushing
packets back and anonymous packets back
is back and forth as fast as we possibly
can right to make sure the link is alive
so those are event-driven you get an
event you know the links alive again an
event you know the link is alive and
when I unplug it it turns out that every
NIC card in the world every NIC in the
world when you unplug the cable raises
an event to the OS but the OSS don't use
it because they assume they're working
through switches and what would be the
point but what we do when I unplug it it
stops immediately but it also notice on
the numbers up there this is just the
last three digits of account the numbers
we're sending what 25,000 a second or
something like that but you'll notice
that they're off by exactly one that's a
miracle if you're doing recovery from a
distributed system failure knowing that
you're off by exactly one is a big deal
so here we go again I will unplug and
they're off by exactly one okay that's
wonderful and you have another red cable
unitary I see and we're gonna you know
show we can do this again and then we're
gonna send an actual message so right
now we're just sending these anonymous
packets
I think Homer would like Marge to buy
some beer so he's gonna he's gonna tell
her to buy beer he's gonna tell her to
buy beer
and or beef either one yeah and he's
gonna send it on one of the active ports
and they're showed up now on Marge Marge
is gonna tell home where she's actually
gonna buy bread but what she's going to
do is send it on one of the inactive
ports whoops
maybe you want to sit around over here
we actually rehearsed this and none of
this crap happened and I want you to
know that okay and she's going to send
it on let's say the second one
non-connected
and of course nothing happens but what
happens if I disconnect this cable and
plug it in it's going to show up on the
corresponding part pour it on the other
side okay so we don't lose these AIT
tokens you don't lose them they are
there now being off by exactly one is a
very good thing for recovery but there's
one thing missing and that's a something
we call tick tock tick the I know that
you know that I know property so if I'm
connected to you over one of these
cables and the link breaks I know it
broke I know that you know it broke and
most importantly I know that you know
that I know it broke because what that
means is we now both know to hold on to
the state we need to re-establish the
message and all the ordering guarantees
that go with it right without having to
exchange message which is the generalist
problem so that's the essence of the
link protocol we're using and the
interesting properties that we get now
it's back to Paul okay Thank You Ellen
so this problem of knowing what's going
on on the other side of a broken link
you know sounds like an impossible
problem right
it says how can but if both sides know
that it broke both sides know what to do
next and that is you know that is kind
of interesting because we're going to
talk about the two generals problem
briefly here but I found this wonderful
picture on the Internet where a computer
scientist told his daughter about this
problem calling generals problem and so
she drew this picture and she said daddy
I found the solutions of the two
generals problem you dig a tunnel I'm
kind of you know what we do is is that
that that that tunnel loggers oh that
goes underneath is a kind of a symbolic
idea of how this can work but we what
we're really doing here is we're
changing the assumptions behind the
common knowledge problem and or if you
wanted to call a generals problem it's
the courier can be seen by both sides
now so if the pakery was a pigeon you
know we can both see that it got lost
and wandered off or what the courier was
was on horseback we can both see that
they got captured and so the fact that
both sides can see the courier is the
change in the assumptions that we're
able to make in these distributed
systems algorithms now what are the use
case for these things
well two-phase commit if you can if you
can create give this protocol to a
two-phase commit protocol you can end up
with a both a safety and aliveness
guarantee and with Paxos instead of
having to have long convergence times
for things that go wrong with taxes
because of the cascade failures by the
way the problem with most consensus
algorithms is that they make an
assumption that each packet fails
independently in other words the rat
protocol in particular that Diego and
Garo has developed here at Stanford has
a wonderful demonstration and it's used
extensively by other systems out there
but the assumption that each packet
fails independently turns out to be
problematic because what happens is when
you're going through a switch network
the switch fails all of the packets at
the same time and so these single points
of failure that caused massive you know
disruption ended up causing multiple
elections to be kicked off at the same
time and then another another example of
distributed
cause is is routing a binary link
reversal protocol which is used fairly
extensively in wireless systems and in
some in some wired systems has this
property that it has an arrow that in
the dag it has the tail of the arrow and
it has the head of the arrow you need to
know if that's being swapped atomically
and if you can guarantee with your
protocol that that's been swapped
atomically now all of a sudden now
you've got much stronger guarantees in
being able to do fail overs much more
rapidly and much more certainly inside
inside the systems so this common
knowledge problem goes from all the way
from you know nobody knows anything
about anything all the way up through
this hierarchy up to everybody knows
everything about everything but the
original paper on this actually boiled
the problem down to a simultaneity
problem you cannot samisen
simultaneously know the knowledge on all
of the places and that really goes
straight back to g2 to relativity to
special relativity in particular so the
fact that simultaneity is a myth you
really can't have it is the underlying
physics what what we're dealing with in
the universe and the common knowledge
problem simply reflects that so what we
were able to do once we have this
protocol is to do even more interesting
things we've got an agent in here which
may be an actor the network interface
controller the blue area is where we
create this deep asynchronous domain
where we're doing this this game with
unobservable presence management between
the cells and what we can do is we can
now do interesting things on top of that
starting with the AIT token which can
then have a payload and say please make
sure this gets delivered to my friend
who or this set of friends that I want
to make sure it gets it so you can do
things like atomic broadcast that you
can't do any other way or at least not
reliably so you could put of all this
functionality into a neck you could put
it all in the software in fact the demo
that you're seeing here is a modified
device driver we're actually doing it in
the interrupt service routine itself so
we're really truly a vendor even and if
you think through the protocol
implications of what we've done building
a protocol that doesn't require any
durations of any kind is really quite
new it's very novel we haven't
that done by anyone else to make that
purely event-driven gives us these
properties of being able to replace
timeouts replace heartbeats and so on
but the opportunity to do more
interesting things in the messages
computationally as well as complementing
the things that are going on
computationally inside the inside the
nodes is that I think we think a new
opportunity and distributed computing so
we could for example build these things
that we call traps or tree graphs this
is the combination of the of the
properties of both but notice that we're
solving the reliability problem by
creating on top of the bare metal this
network asset layer which is a super
reliable lowest level formally
verifiable a small system they're very
base of this thing which can continue to
talk to all of its neighbors even though
in a virtualization environment you know
the operating systems and the containers
and and the applications on them above
can crash and go away and be be replaced
and restarted completely independently
of the what's going on in the network
asset layer so there's multiple layers
on here which we shown the network asset
layers one of the lowest layers of this
protocol the second layer up which is in
this particular color I think is orange
is the data asset layer this is where we
plan to do immutable systems we plan to
put the little data there they
configuration data and the boot images
that you really don't want some you know
enterprise scale ransomware person
coming in and scribbling out where we
can get you back to a known good stay
extremely quickly buying the protocols
at the bottom in the in the network
asset layer providing these guarantees
in the data asset layer to make it
immutable and then that provides
capabilities for the third layer of
which is the computation asset layer
from there we can provide things like
failure detectors as a service we can
provide consensus as a service we can
provide Network assisted transactions as
a service and when I say transactions I
mean fully transactionally consistent
operations that can be perhaps a hundred
times faster than two
commit and perhaps a thousand times more
reliable we think that's interesting
because if you can make transactions
that cheap you can put them everywhere
and now you can build a much more
reliable much more scalable system than
we have been able to before so what I'm
going to do now is switch back to Alan
and we're going to show you a
demonstration on a simulator of where
this system works so yep there it is
okay so I'm gonna have to try to guess
here I can't see very well
where's my mouse okay so let's say you
bought what we're selling okay and
you're gonna build your data center and
you decided you're gonna build a 60 no
data center in a regular grid so you go
ahead and you build it and the first
thing you see is it ain't a regular grid
okay there's wires misplace there's a
wire missing this was what Paul said in
a data center and when you build it out
three to five percent of the wires are
going to be misplaced now in a
conventional system you're gonna send
somebody in there with a flashlight to
either go fix them or figure out where
they really are but what we do is when
the system comes up we do what we call a
discover process which builds a spanning
tree centered on each node rooted on
each node so I'm going to click on a
node here and you're gonna see that
there's a spanning tree and in the
process of doing that building of the
spanning trees we're going to figure out
what the wiring actually is so there's
nobody with a flashlight going into to
see what's going on we just build the
spanning trees and figure out what the
wiring actually is now even though your
data center looks pretty clean there
in six months it's gonna look more like
this thank you you know that we know
that but we still maintain the spanning
trees I click on a link there's a
spanning tree I click on a link there's
a spanning tree I click on a link
there's a spanning tree but when we
build the spanning
trees you see that there are links like
this one right here that isn't in that
particular tree
well we remember stuff about it we
record state about that link so let's
say I go to this link and I make it fail
you notice we just flipped right over
because we knew information about that
spare link now here's a cell that
doesn't have any pruned links as we call
them it just has two children what if
its parent link fails well it just finds
a new route back around so now you'll
notice here that it could have gone this
way and saved one hop it picked the sub
optimal path that's because we're not
only using local information we have no
global information at all that's what
makes this scalable the price we pay is
sometimes a suboptimal route but you
can't make it scalable if you're going
to have centralized information and of
course if a node fails well that's just
a bunch of broken links and we route
around that
okay so think about it what we're able
to do at this point is hide permanent
Network failures from higher levels in
the stack and it means we can enforce
with the TIC type because of the
tick-tick-tick property we can enforce
all kinds of interesting guarantees like
if you're communing on a communicating
and a tree you have message order
guarantees because there's only one path
between any pair of nodes in fact you
can do other even higher level
guarantees now you could compute on
trees in a switch network but what's the
point the switches are dreadful they're
messing up all the neat properties you
get by being on a tree in the first
place with this protocol we get all
those neat properties thank you all
right so what we've done is talked to
you about this link protocol we've
talked about how we can compose it and
what kind of use cases that we have that
we could take it to we think there's a
minute interest here for the academic
community and we think there's
tremendous interest here for the
commercial industry that wants to build
more scalable data centers or data
centers of any scale
you